quand on parle d'al on la surnomme la
dodge ou là deux pattes vous l'aurez
compris je veux parler de la halle de
chevaux et rachid elle a aujourd'hui 50
ans nous allons plonger dans les
archives de cette de chevaux pour
évoquer cet anniversaire avec luc bazin
est tout de suite avec jean jacques
dufour et pierre moscovitch qui nous
emmène faire un tour avec les
inconditionnels de cette voiture dont la
fabrication a été arrêtée en 90
seulement quand on cause bagnole avec un
amoureux de cette fabuleuse boîte de
conserve qu'elle a deux chevaux on
évoque bien sûr ni l'auteur des cuirs ni
la puissance des v8
les 425 dans toute sa splendeur
une voiture qui était donné pour combler
dans les années 60 sur la dame nana le
cahier des charges était 60 à l'heure au
début au début c'était elle était conçu
pour emmener quatre personnes à 60 à
l'heure voilà et puis celle là où la 80
90 et les derniers modèles on arrive à
faire des pointes à 120 leur a quand
même sens pas le sens vannes avait le
vent dans le dos 1
pour les amateurs de pâtes la vitesse
n'est pas un argument d'ailleurs à
l'époque de la conception chez citroën
le mot d'ordre était clair soyez
sordidement économe et oui le plus de
cette auto ce sont ces - elle n'a qu'un
oeil
enfin qu'un phare est seulement une
manivelle pour la mettre en route
vous l'avez reconnu c'est là deux jours
plus tôt l'ancêtre de la deux chevaux
le prototype ou prêt pour le salon 1939
à l'img la tunique qu'elle même âge que
ce formidable moulin à légumes a acheté
sa première 268 depuis il les
collectionne bagnole ça s'explique pas
et sur l'ambiance de rythme à propos de
riz entre 49 et 50 les cadences de
production commence à swinguer et passe
de 5 à mille véhicules par jour ça
marche et c'est logique puisque tout a
été fait pour séduire une clientèle qui
est encore essentiellement rural à la
campagne l'engin est idéal pratique et
confortable elle doit il son cahier des
charges pouvoir transporter un panier 2
à travers champs sans les casser
ça c'est un argument de vente elle peut
le faire
la fai mais la deux chevaux a fait
beaucoup plus raide rallye c'est l'idéal
pour les échappées belles
jacques séguéla s'en souvient en 59 avec
elle il a fait le tour du monde surtout
c'était une voiture convivia c'est une
voiture qui vous ouvrez la porte des
autres qui vous ouvrez le coeur des
autres
je suis arrivé aux etats-unis tu es
notre premier arrêt au bord du bolide
jamais building on a vu un américain
septuagénaire descendre et me dire c'est
formidable vous l'avez construit ou même
quand on veut expliquer mais non c'est
une voiture il a été tellement base
ourdi de savoir que les français
préfèrent ça qui nous a invité à
déjeuner à dîner depuis l'arrêt de la
production 90 les fidèles ne manque
jamais l'occasion d'un regroupement
celui là c'était l'été dernier des
petites voitures qui ont réussi
l'exploit de gommer les différences
sociales de la star à l'ouvrier tout le
monde pouvait en avoir une de trop ça
c'est un mythe dans tous les pays et de
frau c'est la voiture c'est que leurs
deux chevaux
l'orage veut même pas entendre parler
c'est risque quoi cela dit et ça fait
mal au coeur des amoureux de la belle
il y à des jeunes gens qui refusent tout
contact avec elle des jeunes qui pensent
peut-être qu'à 50 balais on ne peut plus
plaire alain vous et trois enfants vous
me disiez qu'il n'était pas très fans
eux en revanche pas du tout
mes enfants aînés 1 pour rien au monde
n'utilisera une deux chevaux gens leur
permis dans leur voiture mais pour rien
au monde une utilisation de chaux et le
pire c'est ma fille qui a 12 ans
caroline qui refusent que je la dépose
devant l'école devant le lycée et au
collège avec une 2 chevaux les filles
partir de vente ul mans de 20 ans serait
plutôt à tirer mais pas les bâtiments
annexes
les petites filles préférés tels les
bagnoles clinquante et tape à l'oeil
je ne sais pas mais dans le doute je
préfère tirer le rideau pour toujours